I I feel like a woman that works at
FoxNews I I'm touched but I'll get to
that but but I can't lie to you usually
I say I know why you're happy I don't
know why you'd be happy - today is a day
Republicans are happy they got their two
favorite things a right-wing [ __ ] on
the Supreme Court and Trump finally
blowing some [ __ ] up I don't know what
we're applauding but okay but yes that's
what happened American cruise missiles
blew up an airfield last night in Syria
because the dictator there was using
chemical weapons which he has done many
times in 2013 ninety eight Republicans
signed a letter saying bombing Syria and
response to a chemical attack was
unconstitutional without congressional
authorization but this is different
because Obama was president then that
would have involved bombing wall black
and you can't dance to that
now this is very tricky for Donald Trump
because the Syrian regime of course is
propped up by Russia and Russia does not
want us bombing there if Trump does the
wrong thing Putin might not reelect him
so but you know what the temptation to
use his do toys was too much of course
you know he's new at this the brass told
him they were going to launch tomahawks
and he said what missiles be better but
you know in America you're not really
president until you bomb something you
know even even though liberals were all
over this last night everybody loves
this [ __ ] thing Cable News loves it
when they show footage of destroyers
firing cruise missiles at night it's
America's money shot of course Trump
made clear that the cruise missiles were
a last resort the first idea was sending
kendall Jenner with a can of Pepsi
interesting a side note to this no
change in the Trump policy on Syrian
refugees coming here Republicans feel
about Syrians in Syria the same way they
feel about the fetus in the womb when
it's a beautiful baby in Syria it's
sacred precious gift from God once it
leaves you're on your own and you know
speaking of protecting fetuses the
Republican Senate has confirmed Scalia
clone Neil Gorsuch for the Supreme Court
proving that in America cheating still
works ladies and gentlemen cheating
still works no conservatives were elated
Bill O'Reilly was so excited he groped
himself Oh Bill O'Reilly had a rough
week we learned it we learned at the
beginning of the week that he has
settled harassment suits from women for
three more in addition to the two that
we already knew about and another two
who weren't suing but are speaking out
bill says he's a target but that's seven
that's kind of a lot not to everybody
Bill Cosby said call me when you get to
30 bills other defense it said it he
says over at Fox News they had a sexual
harassment hotline and nobody calls it
well nobody knew it was there
and also it wasn't a really great one
they would answer the phone Fox News
sexual harassment hotline what are you
wearing
and you know this this is in addition to
roger ailes
you know losing his job because i think
20 women accused him so you know
something i think is going on over there
in fact the cleaning lady at a fox news
said she was there late one night and
she heard moaning and groaning and
grunting her thought it was just steve
doocy trying to do math but it could
have been yeah I mean what one accuser
at Bill O'Reilly says he would call her
and she could tell he was masturbating
possibly because he said I'm
masturbating I think and you know
apparently bill does not take rejection
well because this is woman Wendy Walsh
she was speaking out this week and she
said after he refused to she refused to
go up to the hotel room with him he you
know he didn't like that any any first
thing he did was he insulted her handbag
he will [ __ ] me we'll all have to say to
you is your purse is a lesbian I mean
all these women their stories vary a
little but the one constant is no one
wants to [ __ ] bill Oh
[Applause]
for Bill O'Reilly I mean whether he's
offering you a job or threatening what
you have it's never worth it to [ __ ]
Bill O'Reilly and you know I actually
say conservatives next to be it's just
weird it's just different I don't even
get I'm very proud to say I don't think
I have ever had sex in my entire life
with a Republican it's just too much
work
I don't mind [ __ ] somebody's brains
out but [ __ ] them in